funny that you say like the school days
like mal is either like a 10 or yeah I
was definitely one of those people I
know you didn't cuz cuz I know exactly
what's going on here
school day sucks welcome to trash taste
episode 3 I'm your host corner C dog and
we have the hentai man as always that's
me and the anime zone and you went
straight in there no [ __ ] okay let's
just get this done guys I know I preface
what's the fight this is trash taste
episode 3 I'm your host then we get into
the top yeah but you gotta have like a
can we we need to come up with like some
kind of like you know like how good
musical morning does it yeah like that
let's talk about that like we gotta have
something like that I was going to but
you interrupted me with the you know
what I was gonna say your names then the
topic is gonna be smooth it was not
professional
no no exactly right Wow okay ruining my
turn what I would like to discuss today
with you gentlemen is your anime origin
story if you will how did you get into
anime and how you know you discovered
that you were going to go down this
rabbit hole of never coming this
beautiful medium that we all we all love
[Music]
yeah I mean you wanna go first Joey
because I feel like you have the most
yeah most likely yeah probably I
probably have all yeah yeah okay I'm
having to follow up his story is gonna
be fun but I mean yeah I guess like mine
is unique in the sense that like and
would you say I'm the only Ana tuber
that has like grown up with anime like
and when I say grown up I mean like from
like Age of like conceptual thought age
of conceptual thoughts I think just
being raised in a household to the
Japanese perón yeah probably has an
immediately different attitude towards
anime them that we would experience in
like Western right because like you know
when most people say like oh I grew up
with energy that was my childhood like
like you know that usually starts away
age late you know well yeah
the real question is did you know what
anime was growing up I mean that's all I
ever yeah exactly
okay so so when you were you growing up
in your head even at like age five or
six there's a clear distinction between
like Pokemon and like I don't know we
want the Cartoon Network shows that was
a difference and you knew that they one
of them as Japanese yeah yeah yes like I
because unlike a lot of kids in
Australia and like probably around my
age group I grew up watching Pokemon and
like Dragonball Japanese I thought
Pokemon was an American cartoon people
did my mind was blown at like age ten
when I heard the Japanese version this
is on YouTube clips right like oh wait
this is the original yeah how because to
me Pokemon when I was growing up just
seemed like this very weird
genre like I couldn't put my finger on
yeah but I felt like it was a genre like
it was pokemon digimon Cardcaptor Sakura
which was cardcaptors it in the UK in
America Sakura that's true Asian sound
get rid of that Sakura Sakura
oh and the other girl was like they
changed her name to Madison I think I
can trim all her original name was but
this is this is back in the age of like
four kids dubbing I don't think it was
even even for kids that dubbed
Cardcaptor Sakura but it was in the day
that's you know localization was a thing
we are eating jelly doughnuts cuz you
know like being as you said like growing
up in an Asian household Japanese
household what media was just like the
most like normal concepts like your
breath it's like you know like yeah as
you said it's like bread it's like
watching an American content like
Dexter's Laboratory yeah like a scene of
them making toast for example and it's
over dubbed into Japanese like you know
I'm making a rice ball I think it's just
cause at that time I remember a lot of
my friends just didn't really know the
concept of just eating rice yeah if you
want if you want Asian you're like why
would you eat rice with every meal that
doesn't make sense
great right
I think I can remember what my family
thinking like rice was like exotic isn't
really well I mean it was something you
had with like foreign food yeah so you
don't eat rice but like that's on the
contrary though right like do you eat
bread with everything because at least
in Japan the concept of white bread with
everything is like why I feel like at
least in British culture you could put
bread with anything like you just wear
that I guess I guess like the food I'll
drop that country revolve anyway we're
getting off topic
yeah but so like basically like I grew
up like watching Pokemon and like what
else can remember watching I guess like
before that though like before Pokemon
or anything like that or you know before
I started watching like one piece like
Dragonball like you was shown in jump
stuff like Japanese kids grow up with
this like very certain array of like
kids anime yeah which is just absolutely
not known overseas so Ryan was probably
like the most well known but like you
don't like see a Nana to bow a five
thousand review Doraemon let's go series
that I grew up watching like alongside
thorium or was this show called
salvation yeah which is like the
longest-running just running and yeah
and nobody outside of Japan has heard of
you I didn't know about it until you I
was having perspective in my mom cause
right so it's it's been going on since
like the sixties and I think there's
like five thousand how I don't know
please because like it's really weird
because the concept of that show is like
it's just a revolving around this family
living in Japan and it's just like the
most like normal ask slice of life show
that I've ever seen but I also think to
myself like how can you come up with
like 40 years worth of topics and not be
like oh maybe we did cover this topic
like 25 years ago and one of those
episodes there must be absolute that
overlap like I feel you can't make that
many episodes or not overlap I know I
probably could overlap but nobody
watching that show right it's one of
those things if it's on TV you watch it
right it's like they covered this topic
in episode 1700 there's you know there's
one super fan
apologist in every episode and just
knows everything about every episode but
that seems to be and Doraemon seem to be
the one thing where if you ask anyone
Japan
do you watch anime they'll be like oh
yeah I thought I'm honest yeah and I'm
like oh I'm in like you know the other
anime thing she's no boobs in that
please don't but like but like watching
Doraemon and like saws Ison and like I
couldn't list off a number but late
there's just like a certain number of
shows that I think like it's just become
tradition now no matter what generation
or like if you're born born and raised
in the city or the you know the middle
of nowhere every kid grows up watching
these like really specific set of shows
you know and that's just like it normal
to them you know that's like watching
you know a Peppa Pig yeah it's like it's
just like you don't even think about
like oh yes it's a cartoon yeah it's
just something to show to you yeah right
and then yeah like I guess like the
concept of like anime anime didn't hit
me until maybe like oh I thought when I
started watching like one piece I'm like
Dragon Ball and like probably around
like the Pokemon time so I reckon when I
was like five or six years and white
girl so so when you started realizing
what anime is it probably gets in into
it that's when probably we started to
watch our first anime which was Pokemon
right but like in my head I'm like yeah
Pokemon is an anime and like Samurai
Jack is a cartoon yeah because at that
time like around like five or six years
old that's when I started like watching
like Cartoon Network and I'd like to
think that we grow up in like the Golden
Age of causing Network I mean I'd say so
we had Samurai Jack that's right jack
like Dexter's Lab cow and chicken yeah
anyway so many amazing shows and to me
that's like okay things on Cartoon
Network are cartoons yeah but things
that are on like the VHS tapes that my
grandma would seem to me
oh those animes anime yeah so for me
there's like a really clear distinction
so like I didn't have like one day this
sudden realization there like oh [ __ ]
Doraemon is an anime yeah yeah because
it was just so natural to me see I don't
even remember when I got
realization because I think I must have
got it when I properly started getting
into anime with Naruto was my first like
anime anime and that was purely because
I just kept seeing avatars and you know
gifts on the internet and I was like
yeah this kind of looks like Dragon Ball
Z which I grew up I can't see now I was
ready in - do they have ridiculously
spiky hair exactly right yeah I think I
was on the internet way before I started
watching anime and I think obviously
being on the Internet you see a lot of
anime I just think in all I knew is that
their opinion didn't matter because they
had profile anime profile pictures it's
generational now it's generational
I mean pokeman was the first one for me
I must have been like God I mean Pope
was always one of my favorite shows and
I think we've mentioned this in like
episode zero or something that it had
like an overarching story yeah but you
only really got you don't really get it
actually in anything for like avatar
that came way later yeah like an old
like 90s do you just call avatar anime
oke like cartoon you know you don't want
Courage the Cowardly Dog for the
overarching story right like you watch
chicks it's like every episode it's
great and you have a good time but then
I remember poke one was like oh whoa
they're like actually like working
towards something yes I think as well
like that era of anime as well like I
don't like a lot of cartoons it was like
yes there was like a Masonic moments but
as you said there was like an over they
used you even if it was a filler you
knew they were like they had a goal yeah
yeah and that seemed to be the case
where that kind of structure really like
spoke to me as a first for whatever
reason I really enjoyed that as a kid
and then yeah you had the same thing and
then I thought how all these things with
all the spiky had people there really
like wild drawn things are like I like
these kind of it's so easy for me at
least with you you know is that I didn't
know you yo wasn't anime because I grew
up with the card game first time I got
the card game and then watch them yeah
right because one of your schools
playing Yuki yeah I didn't get that face
I did
I didn't get that yugioh phase we had
ivory because when I was in school
everyone was like trading pokemon cards
and nobody knew how to play the actual
game we are like a black market like
trade deal with photon cards I have like
I had like a really dog like you your
face just like I was like I was legit
like [ __ ] it's like dad because my
dad like used to work for like a
printing company yeah what he would do
is he would find like high-res like
print them out and I would come to
school now if you like my piece of
exodia and I mean like 10 year old
doesn't know but it was funny as well
because like much like your Pokemon
cause you no one knew how to play you
you it was just like oh cool you have
Exodia because I feel like like the rows
of you go were easier to understand oh
come on yeah
oh comes hard yeah cuz I did like I
don't think anyone in my school played
the Pokemon card games you collect them
yeah you just you just collected them
right yeah like it was easy understand
you had a shiny um well that's the thing
though right it's like in order to play
the Pokemon card games you need it to
like not throw away the energy cards
which like my my school like in my
school everyone was just like yep go up
go up go I haven't got lunchtime every
day am I sure yeah but yeah I guess I've
started to realize that I really liked
anime when everyone got into Pokemon
when we had the pokemon card card game
phase as well so yeah just like a global
craze
oh yeah how long did that last that
lasted like a year or something right
well I think or like a few months the
year I was born 1986 I think poke Holmes
the most googled thing
yeah of that year a game it just it just
came out and obviously since that point
onwards it's pretty it through the mid
2000s yeah pretty insane I hope one was
like and arguably still today is one of
the biggest like yeah cuz I just kept
watching Pokemon even after everyone had
like even when the cursor and ever my
mom was my mom without wondering like
why is this kid still into Pokemon
[ __ ] he's going on oh I had the same
thing my parents were like they were
like worried for me they were like
should we like doing he's like do
something about this like he's still
like watching cartoons my older brother
had like foregone cartoons yeah there's
a sign of pride that he's not watching
games like I only watch reality TV show
now with my parents
I don't watch this kids i watch a game
TV yeah right right yeah yeah and I
[ __ ] loved like you know Samurai Jack
like I would always try and watch
Samurai Jack like scars Cowardly Dog
anime as well my parents genuinely like
what concern for me I don't know if they
still are concerns the exact point
because all the way up to university and
when I rediscovered what anime was my
parents were like he's doing it again
pass this [ __ ] phase when they found
out I was watching like more anime than
ever
they were like more concerned they were
like whoa he's gone even harder and yeah
I thought it would stop I remember my
dad like the funniest thing my dad ever
said I think I was in like late maybe
the last year of high school yeah and
that was like when I was like hot this
right before I made my youtube job and I
was like watching every anime ever my
dad would be like what are you doing in
your room because he thought I was doing
something else yeah I know when I told
him that I was watching anime I remember
my dad saying like okay at this point I
think I'd rather you just do drugs I
would have been less disappointed if I
found that you were doing drugs which
ones more life crushing yeah but like I
don't know like I guess like I don't
really have like a phase of like when I
dispute anime or anything because as
long as I've known why do yeah that's
like even mangas well like I started
reading manga like around the same time
that I discovered or I'm oh we just
probably around when I was like four or
five years old howtechs you've been
reading manga since four or five
probably maybe earlier than that but I'd
specifically remember the first ever
volume of manga ever God was volume 2 of
Doraemon I don't know why my mom didn't
get me volume 1 cool like I didn't know
that it was like the overarching story
so I was like oh just start reading this
I had no idea what the [ __ ] was going on
that's all I don't fully 100 now it
makes it's like a wow
mani I feel like my anime thing was like
there's three points in my life where
like I was I conveyed like very vividly
remember watching anime first was like
Pokemon yeah they are occasionally
seeing a yugioh episode of the cards
yeah I think maybe when I got access to
like the Internet
I think that's when another one came
because I remember watching like yugioh
I think it was GX right parts three
parts three parts on YouTube you know it
sounds like an OG anime fan because
they're like oh yeah don't you hate it
when you find an espagnol sub of your
your one okay so envision it right it's
two thousand right you watch episode 1
part 1 of Yuki oh yeah okay cool I'm
gonna watch episode 1 part 2 you click
it it's the next recommended video it's
in espanol thank you do you just do you
like keep looking or you just give up
and go to the next part
yeah I remember so many times I had to
do that what was then that is when you
like could someone uploads like a full
anime movie yeah always always like
either like pot 6 or part [ __ ] one
part that was missing yeah who didn't
find us you just had to give up and just
be like alright I'll just skip 15
minutes I just hopefully try and catch
yeah I think there's 15 minutes of the
first Naruto movie that I've just never
seen it's just I don't know what's
happened it might be the best 15 minutes
of Naruto the max upload time is 10
minutes on YouTube right yeah yeah so
that's why I was plugged into three yeah
and yeah I remember that was like the
one of the biggest and the third part
would always just be like five minutes
yeah yeah there's the outro off of it
yeah yeah no that was like definitely a
big phase for me and I could have been
around 13 14 at that point question to
you then did you grow up during the
Toonami phase because I feel like
tsunami is has played such a big factor
into making the anime fans of today no I
hate for some reason I we did we have
Toonami in the UK we did we did but you
need it you need it Sky TV so I think
you needed Cartoon Network to be so sky
is like basically cable in the UK
wait you guys didn't get consonant with
just like free - no no they've got to
network yes I'm here in Australia it was
free oh wow yes because I know my
parents paid because my dad wanted to
pay for the football matches in the UK
right and you basically got the whole
bundle so I would watch the cartoons
stuff and I remember there's like there
was loads of cartoons I never saw anime
I think it was raring really late
and by there my parents are like why
don't you in bed son because when you
Joe was on the tsunami army it was like
Dragon Ball Z Gundam Wing
Iram the same Dragon Ball never watched
it though cuz I just it was always a
mess because it would they add it out of
order so I was going on I thought it was
cool but I couldn't get into it yeah I
think Dragon Ball Z and Gundam Wing were
the only two I was able to watch
whenever because our family didn't have
Sky TV so I can only watch it when I go
to my cousin's house and I'll be
watching episodes out of order Gundam
Wing made no [ __ ] sense still makes
like I'll be watching a scene and for
some reason the guy wants to kill this
girl but the girl still wants to get
what the guy makes no [ __ ] sense to
me as a kid you know gunner he's already
confusing enough as it is
Dragon Ball Z was okay because I could
just watch I could skip five episodes
and they'd be the same cuz I remember
like I would help you watching these
scenes in Dragon Ball Z yeah and Goku
was like powering up the Spirit Bomb
yeah and then I'd go I I'd not be able
to go to my cousin's till like two weeks
later the Goku was still powering I was
like oh this is just the next episode no
it was like I missed like three four
episodes and it was it was just four
still the same [ __ ] to this day he's
still powering it up hasn't finished man
if he hasn't died for the seventh time
yeah because my my exposure to anime has
got like now that I think back to it
there's there's the main phases of like
the Pokemon phase and then there's the
Toonami phase yeah well I'd see it on
Toonami and TV and then there was this
huge gap I have exact same yeah yeah and
then I did like I realized now that in
the in this huge gap I still had like
small exposures to anime like whenever I
go to Thailand we'd always have these
shitty shitty Thai dubs these are like
that like Ultraman was
was like a massive in Thailand even
though that's even though that's not an
anime but like Dragon Ball Z dubs and
man having listening to Thai doves
they've only got five voice actors and
actresses and they voice every character
in every anime who's growing up in
Southeast Asia
knows what I'm talking about when you
have five voice actors who plays every
character in every show and then my
cousin showed me I think was Princess
Mononoke just our hostess it came out I
didn't know it was animated just like
was this animated film I thought it was
Disney how old are you and you watch it
ah and he came out in 97 yes I must have
been like like it was the year after
came out cuz there's a gruesome movie to
watch I thought I thought that movie was
just Disney and then just just before I
discovered like Naruto air that I went
through the LimeWire phase just for
music though I didn't know no just just
for music same here right so I would be
browsing browsing LimeWire for music I
probably you'd like downloading Linkin
Park or Papa Roach or something like
that and then something else likes you
know sometimes you download a file yeah
and it's not the file you aim for like
it's why you meet everything the Bill
Clinton fine
so in LimeWire someone was just
circulating bible black clips yeah I
never knew that Bible Black was a
Japanese anime because I'm just like
what is this shitty porn that I'm
watching how's the kid as a kid I'm like
oh it's kind of hot though this is
[ __ ] amazing that's exactly how I
discovered it yeah she said in multiple
videos that like going through lime
while obviously looking for the new
Lincoln Pavel just trust people
it was the tentacle scene of Bible black
and she's like this is like she had like
an epiphany she was like this is the
most amazing thing
I can imagine though like because that I
don't even remember I don't want to get
on to the toffee boy I don't remember
how I discovered people I killed the top
because because I didn't I obviously
didn't know it was hentai I didn't even
know it was anime holy [ __ ] I'm having a
[ __ ] epiphany now bible black wasn't
the only hence i downloaded on there oh
my god like i like cuz i remember i
remember downloading full length and no
hentai that came out in the 90s i can't
remember the name but I got why why are
you downloading full length and tag
because I like like I say you just
downloading random files okay and I got
one of these files that are downloaded
was this hence I that icon him the title
had angel in the name this there's a lot
of million yeah yeah yeah angel the name
I'm like what if I just what if I just
put this title into LimeWire and see
what comes up and there were like six
titles that came up so I'm like Colin
I'm downloading all of this how to
destroy your laptop speedrun did you
ruin any laptops or pcs oh [ __ ] oh yeah
I yeah I blamed it on my brother and he
totally got blamed for it but it was
totally me yes III think that I would
have been I think the reason why and I'm
I just realize this now I was wondering
what the [ __ ] was I doing between like
13 and 18 yeah I can picked about it
like it and I just realized I was like
cripplingly like addicted to Xbox like I
it was like every second I got free I
was playing call of duty like that was
like ah friends is well right Nash
that's like the like the Golden Age of
like playing games yeah play with your
friends at school it was like
immediately when I was done I'd go home
play games until I had to go to bed and
I was like the Golden Age of a call it
as well oh my god that was perfect yeah
1 phi2 came out when I was like like
1516 and which is like by the perfect
time to play it I I think I had an age
like a gap as well that I didn't watch
any my nose around the same time yeah I
know exactly why I wasn't but I'm not
gonna say because it's probably yeah but
weirdly enough even though like during
that gap until I probably the last year
of like yeah
school hmm I was still reading manga
like religiously yeah so I don't know
what it is it's like I had this burnout
with anime or maybe just like a loss of
interest with anime of some reason manga
was like always this one thing that I
would just come home and just read the
[ __ ] out of wait just a little more
engaging almost like actively make an
effort oh yeah and also because I just
like reading in general I think so so I
mean a lot of question to you guys what
drew you to anime over like cartoons or
other things like what drew you to this
medium specifically as a child that's a
kid and growing up as well for me it was
just the fact that my mom would just
push it a lot because it was the she
knew that it was the easiest way for me
to appreciate the Japanese culture yeah
[Music]
every time I realized Joey's born on
Japanese I'll speak Japanese god I like
like my mom knew that like if I just
kept talking to her in Japanese yeah it
would most likely stick but she wanted
me to like not just be like competent in
Japanese really the whole cold chilly
like yeah not just appreciate the
culture but also like excel in Japanese
yeah yeah yeah and like thank God
because now I think I have yeah and like
you know I have learned to like
appreciate the culture and just anime in
general in the language and like I did
like you know learn a [ __ ] ton of
Japanese even though I said well in a
lot of videos
don't use animate alone in Japanese yeah
I kind of helped open admit I learned a
lot of Japanese from watching out I mean
any amount of language that you take in
to learn like if you're watching
anything in a language it's good you
know he'll help I feel like as a kid you
just absorb it through osmosis I'm like
oh yeah like I remember learning Thai
just because I was what like whenever
I'd go to Thailand I would just I would
just absorb it whenever talking to my
family or just watching TV shows did you
learn any Thai from the Thai Dobbs
um letter account I can be hard and tie
the same it's just very bad quality it's
it's kind of its kind of like I don't
know there wasn't a lot of money put
into the dubbing industry I reckon so
store more that much - yeah so and we
all we all know a second language then
purely cuz we were just raised yeah
everywhere is spoken yeah yeah but the
thing is well was when you were a kid
you know you have way more time to just
sit there and absorb it when you're in
handle it's uh I get ten minutes a day
on dueling or maybe right where's a kid
it's like eight hours of just you're
hearing this stuff so obviously you're
gonna pick it up but I was just like
like from as far as I can remember with
my childhood like the only memories I
have is just like either watching anime
reading manga or like watching come
right right right yeah so already just
from that like two-thirds of my
childhood essentially is MIA just
absorbing the Japanese language in like
anyway pause right so I think that just
helped me a [ __ ] like if I never got
into anime or manga I would like to
think that I would be nowhere near as
good write the language as I am now I
think definitely for me when I was
watching anime the thing that appealed
to me especially my younger age is that
like I said oh yeah like there's more of
a structure right and there's always an
overarching like point there's no me a
journey to go on and also I felt like
you know I mean this wasn't a problem
back then went with our cartoons you
know the ones a we grew up with yeah I
felt like anime didn't treat the
audience stupid you know like if you're
if you're like 16 18 yeah you know maybe
you don't want to Pokemon you can still
appreciate it and enjoy it and I felt
that like some cartoons I mean I mean
you can watch Samurai Jack any age why
this time yeah there was a lot when I
was growing up there very treated you as
a kid right whereas Pokemon was like
your teenager you're going on a journey
yeah I'm gonna catch pokemon
I was so cool like imagine yourself as
that like it sounds dumb how old was Ash
again - 10 10 10 but I mean but I mean
here - [ __ ] together
like you imagine a mom just letting a
ten-year-old go I to the [ __ ] world
by himself with a [ __ ] rats to keep
him company
I mean wasn't the whole joke there like
the mom sent her off so they just
brought commits crimes are like yeah I
guess that was really irresponsible of
us so I go with a 35 year old man and
Misty okay with like ash hanging out
with like this 10 year old kid life
throws your bike into a river it's like
I'll pay you back
how also as like a ten year old as do
you have any concept of Brock constantly
hitting on people what do you how do you
like perceive that like like what is
that to you is it imagine being broke
and just leaving your family and your
job to like follow this massive family
as well what are you doing nice to say
that kind of reckless behavior really
appeals to me as a kid just I'm leaving
my family that I was supporting we're
leaving my family for what to follow
this tenure also I can go slay some post
it's like it's like strangely
reminiscent of like Hisoka from Hunter
hunter it's like grown man just wants to
follow a kid around see him grow it's
the biggest thing for me though with
late Pokemon that just made no sense to
know is how Gary oak yeah is like
essentially the same ages ash and yet he
can get like all this puss this is it
bad that like I actually like liked
carrying more than a hat and I loved it
when he was a dick to ash I'm like yeah
you should be catching pokémon ash
because he was actually achieving the
goal to become a pokémon master
yeah like I feel like as a kid maybe you
appreciate ash more but hasn't had like
you know Gary's kind of got [ __ ] - yeah
Gary's achieving his dream yeah yeah it
was cool that you saved that bottle free
and reunited a mash but like like but
Gary did but a free start a patron pay
your bills no didn't don't you get a job
ash Gary's Omegas gold split speed one
of the supplies [ __ ]
any % it like getting all the [ __ ] yeah
that man did it all like and yet we
still were supposed to hate him like
like I think when they were like when
Ash was about to like go to like Koga I
think I know Gary just rocks up in a
[ __ ] like Lamborghini like you're
still here who's driving the car yeah
not only is he an expert Pokemon master
he's a logistic expert yeah you're
getting all these women around ya always
an Islam beginning he doesn't worry
about parking tickets I was just walking
is an a duel I think ash is kind of
shitty oh yeah
I mean yeah definitely as a kid that
whole kind of structure and the kind of
you know going on a journey I was very I
will you guys like did you guys feel
really like disappointed when ash got
beaten in the Pokemon oh yeah I was like
this is our destiny like he formed these
artificial bombs with these Pokemon and
he [ __ ] Charles I had the balls to
sleep at the final fight are you serious
jhaza
it was like as a kid it was like top 10
anime twisted you bro
is actually uh there's actually this
really funny thing I have found the
other day when I was learning to like
Pokemon speedruns yeah yeah you know the
other thing called ash percent to play
the game exactly like every Pokemon
exactly the same oh my gosh you have to
release your Butterfree you have to
release your Charizard and then you have
to purposely lose at the would drive me
mentally 9 oh my god shirtless mario
speedrun yeah you do basically just your
speed run mario ought to see where you
try and get mario sure let's cruise
possible yeah I love the troll speed
runs
anyway we got off-topic okay and I don't
know well it was it the same thing as
well for you as a kid yeah I like I
don't know I couldn't quite put my
finger on it but it was this huge
overarching plot like they had a goal
and they were working towards a goal
like Pokemon turned out to me my like
as as I watch more anime I started
liking Pokemon less and less like when I
things like Digimon came and they had an
actual like story arc my Charizard at
the most crucial moment did you want for
me was probably the moment when I
actually fell in love with anime yeah do
you want to know something I never
watched the Digimon anime did you know I
watched it the only things I anything
Digimon that I ever like consumed are
the two movies I played the games as
well as a kid and the other thing I
remember is them being hot as [ __ ] are
they are well there are games of that
there's games and like I think at least
the Digimon World Games I don't know how
old they are I remember like thee
they're like some of the hardest games
to get like full completion any games
ever like they're like insane and I
remember as a kid thing like the [ __ ]
why can't I get past the first level I
beat all of Pokemon in French I what the
hell like yeah no I never I don't know
what it is maybe because I was just so
obsessed with Pokemon yeah but like I
always knew Digimon was a thing yeah but
I never watched any of it was always the
joke is a kid right you would like the
[ __ ] comedian if you yeah I guess
you're the did you know no one wants to
be the Digimon [ __ ] I have a question
for you specifically okay this isn't
apply to you but did you like as a kid
have a sense of like oh I kind of like
this whole like Japanese culture thing
whenever it propped up you know in like
TV or anything I mean to me was less of
a less exotic cuz to me it was like
Asian culture I guess yeah yeah yeah
because it was it was I had seen more of
it because I you know I didn't exactly
grow up in Thailand but I would visit
there at least once a year so I'd spend
like my summer holidays in Thailand
every year so seeing some of more
Japanese culture the more Asian oriented
culture it's not that different from
what you get from fly-ins Asia like
Japanese specific like say onigiri I
didn't have no idea what the five before
but I could see that all it was just a
ball of rice I know Ric is I can see
what this is I guess it's a difference
of me coming from you know the whitest
place on earth and not not being exposed
to any other especially Asian cultures
you know yeah yeah the only Asian
exposure I had you know apart from media
was just like the shitty Chinese shot
that you know down
a dress like we've had awful Chinese and
so I think whenever I saw Japanese stuff
in media I thought it's so cool like I
it's gonna sound so [ __ ] dumb that
were the same go on you know you're more
like jackass the movie or whatever
whether they wear like one of them goes
to Japan oh yeah sounds like just
stripping in a store and dancing yeah
the whole time I just didn't know what
that like dude look at those [ __ ]
appliances they have I thought it was so
cool they had all these appliances in
the store like I've never seen them like
because in the West we never got those
like TV and radio built in yes and like
they had like the numbers on the side I
thought those were cool as [ __ ] as a kid
and then obviously watching like samurai
stuff and then Samurai Jack was a huge
thing that made me think like I [ __ ]
love samurais oh yeah they were like the
coolest things to me I think I think it
was either like we're depending on if
you were into anime oh yeah like the two
things that got people into samurai were
either Samurai Jack all the locks I can
still watch Samurai Jack today and like
[ __ ] love my Jack ride like a baby
Samurai Jack is just a [ __ ] great
show Jack was like the one constant
Network show other than ed and Eddy that
my dad would be just as excited to watch
it was like dude like I remember like
the episode we'd like the assassin do
you remember this one would they like
that the robot dog and I love that
episode all my favorites but uh I think
in my head looking back now I feel like
it was inevitable that I was gonna get
into anime cuz I had like a fondness for
Japanese culture well it wasn't like
intense a we be a thing I like the
movies I like the like all the culture
that I saw I loved video games and being
a video game fan you're gonna run into
like stuff so you're like huh why is it
like this and you're like oh it's
Japanese yeah and then also watching
anime from a young age and like yeah
so I felt like it was inevitable at some
point in my life I was gonna find anime
and be like I [ __ ] love this [ __ ] yeah
my I feel I completely forgot about
video games and just like JRPGs oh it's
it's a big push you don't realize not
really exactly I mean yeah and I realize
a lot of the same story tropes that drew
me to anime like I liked in JRPGs and to
JRPGs as well I guess remember the time
when Japan just felt like this foreign
oh yeah concept oh yeah yeah like this
was where this is way past even when me
discovering anime but I mean I remember
like after discovering an amazed
discovering Naruto and everything you
know it was so weird to find anyone who
went to Japan or see any kind of like
Japanese media even outside of the Japan
I feel like it's only recently become a
tourist destination yeah you know like
like if my my parents who like never
want to leave Europe right like they're
like if it's not Europe it's not a
vacation if they're considering like Oh
career and Japan sounds cool like if
they don't like that I'm like okay well
now I guess everyone's up to it now are
they thinking that yeah they were
planning they're not just because I
lived here but they were gonna they one
of the car anyway
and yeah I feel like there's that kind
of mainstream nurse of it anyway as
really like had a big impact recently
cuz I remember when I first started
watching stuff on YouTube there was no
like vloggers like I've been watching
like a Chris broad video from like years
ago yeah and he was like the only guy
right he was one of the oh geez right
like the thing yeah and I remember back
then like if you wanted to find certain
Japanese they were had to be like a BBC
documentary yeah yeah someone going
there right yeah like it was not a
youtube the weird wacky world of Japan
ya know like you can find out anything
you want about exactly like it's not
hard but I remember yeah like same thing
you'd see you see these weird
commercials you'd see like these clips
from these talk shows or the variety
show
yeah and you're like what the [ __ ] is
going on in this country takeshi's
Castle at 7:00 a.m. every day the
challenge I used to wake up early before
school and I would like watch every
episode over like I literally watched
takeshi's castle all throughout high
school no no same in those reruns oh
yeah I loved it every time yes the same
episodes over and over it's like it's
like watching Top Gear and down you know
it's like it's it's something you could
always watch over and over and it was
just so [ __ ] weird usually that I
found out though that like takeshi's
Castle you guys had the console yeah and
they're really interesting because
that's a shirt from the 80s yeah yeah
it's strange cuz I think America has
their own version as well by the way
takeshi's Castle is this kind of
physical the most extreme Game Show was
it called like did your warriors
something like that like what's like the
moment you
but imagine if it was like all the
contestants were just everyday people
and it was horribly unfair yeah it was
so unfair and it was so fun and it was
just brutal these these courses they
would just send people and they were
ninja warrior' across the jackass yeah
[ __ ] dangerous I mean there's a
reason why they don't do that show any
no no no legit oh yeah yeah that show
had a huge following in the UK because
of rally and and I think America did as
well but each each localization had a
different style to it sir the Japanese
mom she just showed the show yeah a
British one had like this Craig Charles
a Charles who's have quite a famous
person back in the 90s right yeah
because he did Robot Wars right right
yeah it was really big in America they
had like a kind of imagine like a pseudo
kind of football commentators been like
what do you think of that Jeff yeah he's
supposed to be like kind of like jokey
thinks I should watch clips of it it's
not as good but each country a Terran
localization yeah okay was huge because
I remember those petitions even when I
was like 16 17 people wanting to bring
it back but I mean how can you bring it
back by just dumping over the old but a
Thailand actually had I think a version
like a few years ago as well okay they
made their own version I know because I
remember watching and thinking like not
the same thing quite scratch but that
was a huge factor in why also I love
Japanese culture because you watch that
show in light it's it's crazy it's
amazing and it's also a blatantly
extremely Japanese yeah you're seeing
like katakana kanji everywhere like it's
obviously just like it's it's purely
jazz like ADHD like editing you know I
know it's pure like yeah that's my first
introduction to like using Japanese your
chaos I don't know but what it is about
Japanese variety shows it's just about
having as much information on screen to
like distract your eyes as possible I
start making YouTube videos I have come
to like feel sorry for every Japanese
editor oh the sheer amount of texts they
have to put on the screen changing
colors and [ __ ] popping up everywhere
because everybody's dialogue has
sometimes it's like we can hear them
fine do you know what I hate when I
whenever I see like an anime trailer and
it's from like Japanese TV so they
always go like this guy reacting to a or
something oh in the corner
and they're not even reacting that was
they just lame yeah yeah yeah game shows
they'll have like yeah and really like
like normal thing others have a guy in
the corner like yeah it's like a really
interesting behind-the-scenes clip of
this anime or show well like one of like
I remember seeing like the giorno Kent
clip of the guy doing muda yeah right
and there's just a gargantia in the
corner I was like I don't give a [ __ ]
about my guys taking up valuable screen
yeah I have to say that like with
takeshi's castle yeah I [ __ ] loved
growing up
oh my job I sure what was your guys like
favorite like segment of that show
because for me like to this day if I
have a bad day I'll always watch clips
of the ocean staircase see I think they
have different names for them yeah yeah
challenges title screens yeah I could
tell that they called try to mimic I
mean did you guys watch like the lotion
stay case is like they it's like a giant
staycation it's just covered in lotion
and oh yeah yeah yeah I remember that
one I like I like the the one where they
would the the honeycomb maze like the
hexagon maze although I was really this
maze and like and you got a up top down
view which is so good and you would see
them go through this maze and they're
basically these [ __ ] dudes which grab
them in the face there's also like the
rolling things that they know the one
the one of things that's my mind is the
one where they're like rock skipping
like just like you you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] go full pelt over these like
rocks over a river and some of the rocks
would just would just sink yeah I'll
just imagine if like you're running full
pelt and then one of the rocks sinks and
you just faceplant into a real rock oh
my god I'll live to painful if you
haven't watched it you're in for a treat
it's just it's so good it's such good
fun I don't think a show like that good
command of issues causal they're like
there's so many shows that either
America or the UK or like some Western
countries like off like silent library
oh yeah wipeout alais they're all and
even like ninja warrior they're all like
a regionally Japanese owari are watching
the Japanese version they could never go
as crazy as a [ __ ] No
mean ya know it's crazy I mean I think
that was definitely game shows like
everything kind of got me into anime
Ryan like it was just that kind of
buildup of I kind of think this culture
is kind of sick right and I like what
they do I like all the media that they
put out like you know just jives with me
right now I just seem to enjoy it and
then I remember the first like anime
anime right this is where we're talking
about like finally getting into like
there should yeah oh [ __ ] yeah I
remember I really force up for some
reason I wanted to be like a TV and film
snob I don't know why I wanted to be
like I've seen everything I think I feel
like everyone's gone at this point yeah
everybody I feel like it was in it I
just finished watching like 24 in Prison
Break and I was feeling like man I'm
such TV connoisseur I've watched Prison
Break in 24 so I went to went through
the list and and Death Note was like
eight for something at the time Wow nice
and I this must've been like mm yeah
1213 yeah and I skipped it or initially
because I'm like watching [ __ ]
cartoons yeah I'm a grown-ass man I grew
up because it was real again cuz like
you know my parents and they're all my
family and cousins and whatever like
they were telling you like dude stop
watching cartoons right your honor
alright so I initially skipped it but
for some reason I did a double take like
two or three weeks later read the
synopsis and I thought okay this sounds
pretty [ __ ] sick yeah yeah and if
it's in the top ten it's got to be
pretty good right yeah watched one
episode I I had to school the next day
but I stayed up the whole night up until
school I had to leave with two episodes
left yeah a wash I binge did the whole
season of Death Note yeah one night and
oh my god I just immediately feel I
became obsessed like it was like
overnight I had just come like all my
other plans to watch all these famous
movies and TV show yeah get that out of
someone on YouTube said watch Code Geass
so I'm gonna do that yeah and it's just
like obviously that phase where you
discover all like the golden anime it's
just like Bangor after Bangor and it's
like three months straight where you're
just like all you think about is
watching the next Anam good like
remember that thing I've missed that
fall so much everything she watched was
amazing you know like I look back at
some of the [ __ ] now like going through
this phase where I was
I was obsessed with Love Hina right okay
if we all had that face back of the day
can I ask what was the show that ruined
that for you I do remember because I
know exactly how it was for me not
because like I feel like once you
watched enough anime or you start like
do you remember the feeling of the void
right avoid where you watch this really
really good show you're like no one's
gonna top this not nothing's gonna top
this and you just feel empty
hit your boo oh and then and then the
more shows you watched more the more
that void shrinks right they were like
you find the next amazing show right you
were like and then you watch enough and
then you find like your top ten favorite
shows yeah yeah and then that's that's
kind of when it starts cementing for me
to like to the next phase where you
start watching stuff and it's not as
good a feeling as when you first started
so what was it for you then school days
cuz I I decided I distinctly remember
this okay and I remember being really
annoyed about it and I'm not saying that
for the meme is totally accurate cuz I
can I never escaped school okay so you
want to know you all know what's even
worse right is that so I was watching
anime on YouTube still at this point
right so I remember because I would get
I'd get a my anime list because that's
what I have one did right like you would
look at which ones are high rated and
which ones yeah for some reason school
daze was like one of the highest rated
but but it was like it was like it was
like split right between light it was
either a 10 or a 2 yeah and I thought
I'm gonna be in the 10 calories yeah
everything I've watched so far [ __ ]
long yeah so first off I already had a
bad start watching school days because I
remember watching school days HQ or
something and it was like like a
spin-off it was like 40 minutes of
course cool days HQ to explain is the
original visual novel of school days but
the original visual novel of school days
was basically just a full-on anime yeah
right it was all animated I didn't know
that this is the first time I just found
that out yeah so you can watch you can
watch all the school days HQ on
something like pornhub or less videos
which if you're really just like no
if you're really just looking to watch
the you know clips that you're looking
for you can just find it oh and they
would have showed the clips and that I
didn't get that far I got about soos a
40 minute episode one right and I
watched 40 minutes and I was like this
isn't this isn't seem right am i
watching the right thing like everyone's
saying it's good right it's so funny
that you saying like the school days
like mal is either like a tan or yeah I
know you didn't say [ __ ] going on here I
know what mindset you're in where you
were like every time I'm in the [ __ ]
hood that sheep right who everyone else
is set at 10 and he doesn't want to be
that one guy who's like I don't think I
have good taste no way I have good taste
I can appreciate it Scott because for me
right like school days was like it was
crap until the last episode because the
last episode I was like first of all I
remember just like sitting there I'm not
gonna say it but I'm sure there's lots
of maleic school days for me that ending
just like the most satisfying thing I'd
ever seen it okay okay I will give you
that it was satisfying but then I
remembered like I just sat through 11 of
the most boring [ __ ] in my life yeah and
I don't think this is big enough to
redeem it like the first the first 11
episodes was just like I think I need
anger management right yeah yeah oh my
god I hate the main character so my
whole and then I've gone and then he's
like the [ __ ] orgasm you got an
episode 12 where what happened happens
and you're like oh yeah that ending for
me made it it in no I specifically
remember I'm like I'm glad I went
through those 11 episodes going no
that's satisfying that's [ __ ] that
is bullet that's recency bias right cuz
you're you're basing your review of how
it ended not the [ __ ] the absolute
[ __ ] truck they do it to like a shovel
okay no but let but he's the thing right
like i I've said this so many times in
videos but like the ending for me is so
[ __ ] important because like I had got
that goldfish brain but iTunes
everything outside
the opposite experience with Deadman
Wonderland no I selected my guys cuz
they may wanna let for me was amazing
first 10 episodes and the ending was
just the most garbage [ __ ] II like
okay we ran out of budget ending that
I've ever seen that it just completely
ruling class doesn't mean it's a one I
mean I get devil in Wonderland the anime
yeah like a 5 what no no it's better
than a 5 because then I read the manga
and the monk is infinitely better you
think so yeah I thought whether because
the manga actually ends it's better than
the [ __ ] anime I guess I am a reading
Deadman Wonderland and I kind of liked
what it did a little bit but the ending
I wasn't too big with fan over them all
right but even if it was like a mediocre
ending right ending at least I got an ok
ending whereas the anime just left me
wanting more and I'm like don't [ __ ]
tease me like that after 10 amazing
episodes would you rather a show that
has like 10 amazing episodes with with
no ending or 24 episodes with 10 amazing
episodes and it starts to go kind of man
the endings a little questionable the
first writers what we got with dead man
there yeah angers and that's why I but
like oh I'm trying I'm just trying to
like wrap my head around how you could
justify like I've just been sitting here
for like the past few minutes having a
[ __ ] mental let me let me rephrase
let me rephrase okay I had so many
opinion changes on the ending to school
days like sorry okay so what would you
give school days now then now I would
give it a 6
no no I had a phase where I'm like is
this ending genius or is it the worst
garbage if I if I like you know if I
make a character that is so [ __ ]
abhorrent and then I kill him off oh
yeah you should he's not even a good
character like there's not a good
character it was exactly the reason why
the ending all it's satisfying but it's
just so [ __ ] surface-level you know I
mean I wouldn't watch it again he he
liked this protagonist it's the one that
we follow he made this character dog
[ __ ] on purpose but then there's also a
little bits where he tries to make you
like the guy and that's the words right
and that's what I [ __ ] hey is like no
don't try
we sympathize with this con you had like
a threesome in like class three be like
what the [ __ ] you just had like a dad
that's the one character development
that uh what the folks Makoto had that's
noses named makoto valued I complete
because he's so [ __ ] plans I couldn't
even remember his [ __ ] I can't
remember any of the character I love the
one derivative all the Makoto hat is
that he started out as is like absolute
synthase kya needs of these most like
the Giga chat and I'm the episode for me
that made me like had to like pause and
go like was like the wind when they want
one of the have like a threesome
I like Poston I was like should chop
them up there chop the [ __ ] mutt
there so like like it was literally a
porn plot how it happened it was
schooldays hate you there's a pond
that's the worst thing about it right is
it they try and sell you that it's not a
poor plot and then they hit you with the
in front of my salad plot and you're
like no this isn't what I want like and
the fact that people on mal had the
[ __ ] balls to be like this is an
artistic masterpiece of our generation
the timing is impeccable it's like no
it's like it's like yeah okay if my dog
got rabies and I watched it die that for
three hours yeah I'd probably see it put
down B would be satisfying right because
it's just suffering that's what that
anime was he was just suffering I
[ __ ] hated it and the fact that I had
to then watch 40 minutes of a let's play
or whatever the [ __ ] it was the first
thing I did watch that and the worst
part was is that imagine okay before you
could even start the dog [ __ ] power that
is the [ __ ] school days you had to
watch 40 minutes of the same thing
before you started the same thing again
so I remember watching the first episode
already bored out of my mind because I'd
seen this [ __ ] before in it in a
slightly different way and I was like
okay I hate school this school day sucks
[ __ ] I'm just having a [ __ ] mental
breakdown right now because I thought I
had left school days in the past I never
thought I'd hear though
two words again I'd be sitting next to
the guy who Lucas cuz I remember that
mal phase and I thought they must
everyone must be trolling yeah this is
like the interspecies reviewers kind of
thing everyone's giving this a ten
everyone's being [ __ ] ironic there's
no way that there can be a guy I'm sure
there were I'm sure there were but like
I can't imagine I couldn't imagine you
all ironically gave it a turn I just
can't I just I just remember like I had
a video like this is look were you
corrected your opinion no not enough I
mean two videos I had I had a video the
first video I ever made on school days
was right after I finished watching it
and I think like a six year old video
it's cold like is the school days ending
a masterpiece or something like that oh
my god it's just like me going like yeah
yeah okay it's like it's like imagine if
Code Geass is ending right you had that
but then 25 episodes was just as fun
following like like Nunnally like just
yeah her daily life you know I mean like
that shit's boring I don't [ __ ] see
it's like it wasn't like okay the ending
was satisfying but it was just it was
just a boring show it was a boring show
for half of it and then the second half
was just like anger management I think I
gave us such a high score because I just
appreciated the meta behind how the
director and producer chose the little
worst ending of any visual novel in
existence it was like grade-a trolling
in my opinion and I think that's why I
said it was kind of Jean I mean it's
definitely different like that anything
was not like an ending like that we you
don't I said why we're still talking
about school days after [ __ ] how many
years of it's me now yeah but okay
here's the thing right is that sometimes
what what is a good ending right is it
is do it do you think it as a good
ending because if the story made sense
it really like in the whole thing it was
like wow that's a great ending it really
made sense all the characters
built up to this no it's a good ending
because the main character was [ __ ]
awful and everyone in that show was
god-awful yeah we just wanted to see
them get like revenge but I'm like but I
would argue that like an ending that is
good right doesn't necessarily have to
be memorable right there's a difference
between a memorable ending
and a good it's a memorable I mean it's
just like pure shock factor right it's
just like pure shock factor and it's got
not much substance behind that shock
right right right
and that was my big problem with school
days because at least with the visual
novel you could see [ __ ] sex scenes
for one get some tips he's getting 316
oh [ __ ] exactly cuz ELISA in that what
he actually makes made sense why he was
getting all this [ __ ] [ __ ] did it
did it made sense because he was the
[ __ ] hint I'm the visual what in the
anime because they didn't explain the
hentai sub porn yeah or the subtext I
guess that it is like a hint I I think
that was the first time as a teenager
there that I was like Oh sex again like
really we're gonna go with sex again all
right geez that's like the age where
like you start to be like beyond those
kinds of like six and poop jokes where
it's all about like like challenging my
sixteen-year-old atheist brain then it's
not good material you know I mean I'm
pretty sure I watched that like peepee
poo-poo thing that made me laugh on
YouTube like two weeks ago so I don't
know why I'm fully gone but right but
like it always goes back right light
you'll often poop jokes at age 10 not at
age 15 and then you'll offer poop jokes
again at age 20 I being a teenager is
[ __ ] weird that's actually it is
[ __ ] whiff because teenagers we horny
as [ __ ] right yeah I guess when you're a
teenager you wanna this is weird thing
that you don't do as an adult right when
you're an adult you fully accept what
you're into as a teenager you're like
trying to mold your interest into what
you think yeah yeah yeah I felt like the
shows that you watched which is probably
why this guy gave mallet
I have [ __ ] schooldays of Tani's like
I want to be this smart you can see
through all the [ __ ] to see that
masterpiece I fully admit that's exactly
right
I'm not gonna sit here and say like I
did that too right yeah I'm out there's
a part of me that would argue that
Prison Break was a masterpiece of art
I'm right when I look back now maybe the
[ __ ] was like thinking I was 15
yeah you know like it's when you're a
teenager you have dumb opinions
you should never start an energy channel
in your no no you're very highly
regretted later on my first video was on
[ __ ] bleach how old do you started
YouTube then 17 oh [ __ ] okay I would see
I would do still do dumb [ __ ] up until
20 yeah I started my youtube in 19 right
holy crap some of the stuff that I said
I I look back now and you know you look
back and you know the motives as well to
why you said the dumb [ __ ] yeah yeah oh
never have now right of course
like you you're like I want to be seen
in this way so I'm gonna say opinion
that isn't really mine but I don't know
who will view me if I like I look like
my son my first videos and I [ __ ]
cringe man I could not finish them oh my
god I'm so [ __ ] glad that the way the
internet was it was like the perfect
time I think for when I was growing up
because like yeah there is still the
kind of thing of you could say whatever
the [ __ ] you wanted I got away with it
right like I'm sure I said some [ __ ]
horrible stuff on runescape and Xbox
Live people right off like you know now
I mean kind of stuff gets hold against
you yeah yeah I'm glad that I had that
room to grow room to know that school
days was garbage you know without having
to make a video about it I mean my
school days is a masterpiece guys
actually make a video what you did you
did
oh your channel we're watching five
minutes I kind of watch it cuz so cringy
but it's like me and like a [ __ ] late
during the era where like known as the
guy as to where the wheel hats yeah I
had like I had a like a chop I had those
like the hugely chop behind and I was
also wearing this like rainbow beanie
with like a scarf attached to any [ __ ] I
love to cross to save the leaves I don't
know why anyone was like oh yeah this
guy's looks good but like yeah like on
ironically I was like you know what now
that I'd like mulling it over I think
school days is ending is really freaking
good
and it's a channel right now like I'll
keep that [ __ ] up because it is getting
a drive he's gonna I can't I like to
keep it up until I kind of remind my
audience that like you know I used to be
like this but now obviously I've changed
my view on school days and a lot of
shows because I've as you said
had the room to grow now and the room to
watch yeah I think it's funny to look
back here old videos where your cringes
[ __ ] yeah I used to be like this is what
I'm like now you know yeah I mean you
can see clear improvement I like I like
seeing the growth you know yeah yeah
that feels good it feels it hurts to
watch some of your older videos I
actually watched it and I'm like I sound
so much more British yeah so [ __ ]
mind
I didn't realize such a northern accent
yeah start of YouTube well when I made
you you have like the thickest Walsh
accent yeah it's kind of been like
destroyed yeah which is nice you know I
mean I use to be clearly here but I
think that's to coincide with all like
YouTube growth I think you have that as
well especially in your tastes and anime
when you're a teenager and what you like
and you know you can allow yourself a
trash taste for a reason
Joey's Joey's really pulling his weight
on that this episode has been on [ __ ]
point and to bring the trashy and
alright if Seoul is gonna do is gonna be
me like why is it every podcast someone
I can never escape for that's why I
think it's that it's that moment as an
anime fan when you watch school days and
it's like two paths which one are you
gonna go are you gonna go down like just
admitting your tastes
this is like the modern-day like Pokemon
versus Digimon yeah school days good old
school days back it's like the anime
litmus test thank you well school days
just way more culturally important for
the anime fandom than I've realized that
least for you know in the mid you know
2010 that right yeah I think that was a
big like taste indicator oh and also
anyone who said they liked it was a
[ __ ] liar at the time you know no
because at that time I remember this I
felt like I was too [ __ ] the idiot
cuz I'm like the only guy that thinks
the show is garbage like okay school
days come out it was like 2007 it was it
was during the Golden Age okay so 2007
yeah yeah cuz I think it was 2006 saying
that right I watched that at like 2013
yeah and that was just that argument was
still going on yeah until 2013 and a
Sonic's aspect that's still going on
today
obviously a lot lesser but I mean you
can argue that we brought it back yeah
how many anime do you know that have had
like discussions like that where it's
like brought up time and it's so
decisive well right I think this is the
only anime that's like properly trashy
you know enemies no it's no trap that it
just keeps being brought up because I
can you know point shows like say
Evangelion or something that's you know
we can discuss till the end of times and
fans probably will discuss that too at
the end of time but in terms of like
shows that I count as [ __ ] awful yeah
um school days is just a show that just
doesn't a few slice the [ __ ]
cockroach every time I step on it every
time I think it'll never escape from it
dude that's that's the beauty of school
20 oh my god I love how this was just
like search for your origin story in
Texas the downfall of anime the absolute
[ __ ] roasting of my 10 out of 10
opinions just like a Brazos of anime you
know it's just like that's basically
what it is it's like an action if like
if a browsers had a good ending we
probably all be arguing about it right
that's the equivalent it's like it's not
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so heated about
it I just it gives like a visceral
reaction to everyone who dislikes this
guys are living adapt I'm just looking
forward to the giant discussion this is
gonna cause and like the Sabra it's
gonna be a whole threat again this time
I am interested to see what you the
viewers you have seen school they think
of it and yeah if you're wrong on I mean
I I said anything else we can talk about
over then I think that's a good place to
end if yeah I feel like that's that's
just took the wind out of my sails I
don't know how I can possibly be calm
about anything else today but you do
have something important about our we've
actually started the trash taste patreon
as you can see the production value is
quite high for this podcast and we have
editors helping us and stuff and it's a
whole system that we have and sadly it
doesn't fund itself it's a lot of money
to run basically I just want to talk
about because you know I feel like when
we were making this podcast we didn't
want to settle for like cheap production
values we wanted this
to be you know comparable to any other
high budget pot yeah yeah like to us
this was a passion project yeah
we've put quite a lot of our own savings
into that's an understatement
expensive like you know several thousand
dollars into making this and plus you
know we are renting out a studio you
know in Japan a lot of time a lot of
money yeah new Tokyo so right now like
not to say that we you know all three of
us are pretty well off we'd be fine if
we just don't want our passion project
to be bleeding money which right now it
is ya know so any any help that you can
give to help us just to you know go even
cuz that's that's my goal if yep I can
do this and not have to worry about
losing my thing like just constantly
losing money and you know then I would
be more comfortable and I will just be
happy yeah and hopefully with your guys
are support to why we'll be able to
evolve this podcast into like bigger and
better future yeah and and if you want
just a standard viewer who you know
doesn't care what patron anything don't
worry about it nothing will change with
trash tastes gonna be anyway you get
everything don't worry about it they
don't the patrons don't get anything
we're not gonna pay wall anything yeah
yeah and please again we'll be fine
financially if you don't support it yeah
totally fine it's purely optional he
only option know if you like a podcast
yeah what else be able discuss anything
else we need to shout out or anything
we have Twitter yeah trash taste pod you
can also send us your memes and toppy
suggestions there as well and we also
post photos and videos of dog [ __ ] that
we do so if you enjoyed that before you
[ __ ] is ask again it will be going on
Spotify and Apple all that stuff
eventually if it isn't already it will
be soon don't worry at the time of
recording
I'm really hoping by the time this comes
out yes already so check the description
yeah I'm sure we're gonna have an ant
over in the description whether this
will definitely nounce it on the
subreddit and Twitter yeah so yeah let's
check that out but without further ado
this has been trash taste and thanks for
watching guys see in the next episode
yeah alright bye
I can't [ __ ] believe school days this
[ __ ]
[Music]